[Applaudissements]
car si j'ai pas prendre qu est ce qu
elle veut lapin oulémas pomme allez-y
mais elle croit que j'ai pas apparemment
la fin à la faim oui c'est voulu dire
quand même ce que c'est un oui un pomme
n'en voulait la pomme c'est un peu ça la
gênait vous étiez pas prêt à manger je
pense que décidément fait attention aux
pépins cola les palaces et j'ai un peu
faim mais c'est pas une pomme
si c'est une pomme ça se paye pop 600
femmes donnez-lui qu'elle se ménage
je lui donne la pomme oui j'ai un petit
peu faim si vous la mangez pas est-ce
que je peux toujours sous 12 97 qu'avait
excusez-nous soit elle voulait tomber la
tour des mois suivants bref allez y à
tailler une banale et jeudi s'est passé
s'est mise à jour apple
oh merde ah bah oui 5 fruits et légumes
1,5 et bien évolué et c'est lui qui va
être déçu ce soir
s'ajoutent à eux et plus c'est bon non
mais quand même attendre quelqu'un est
malade non mais arrêtez pas trop moi je
connais moi ça ici non mais ça suffit
non conservé c'est bon
[Rires]